focus is the
sort of prerequisite for basically uh
you say knowledge work but
basically any kind of skill acquisition
any kind of major effort in this world
can we break that apart a little bit
yeah so so
a key a key aspect of focus is not just
that you're you're concentrating hard on
something but you do it without
distraction
so a big theme of my work is that
context shifting
kills the human capacity to think so if
i if i change what i'm paying attention
to to something different
really even if it's brief and then try
to bring it back to the main thing i'm
doing
that causes a huge cognitive pile up
that makes it very hard to think clearly
so even if you think okay look i'm
writing this code or i'm writing this
essay and i'm not multitasking and all
my windows are closed and i have no
notifications on but every five or six
minutes you quickly check
like an inbox or your phone that
initiates a contact shift in your brain
right we're gonna start to suppress some
neural networks we're gonna try to
amplify some others
it's a pretty complicated process
actually there's a sort of neurological
cascade that happens
you rip yourself away from that halfway
through and go back to what you're doing
and i was trying to switch back to the
original thing even though it's also in
your brain's in the process of switching
to these emails and trying to understand
those contexts
and as a result your ability to think
clearly just goes really down
and it's fatiguing too i mean you do
this long enough you get midday and
you're like okay i can't
i can't think anymore you've exhausted
yourself
you